thank you very much it's a real pleasure
to see you all so early morning and to
welcome you all to see on behalf of the
school I'm pleased to over the
conference and to welcome all I want to
say a couple of words about the
enterprise that you're going to be
engaged in today I should apologize in
advance that as soon as I say like three
minutes of stuff on that run because one
said that my exalted title come all
kinds of being too so I'll have to dash
but I'll be back later in the afternoon
to hear something about some of but i
think it's especially fitting and
pleasing to me that this conference is
being held at sea because it brings
together a number of topics that are
extremely important to columbia
university to the school of
international
I think to the global study of public
policy that we are engaged in school the
papers that you will be delivering
discussing talking about it with of
course today deal with a number of the
most pressing global policy challenges
the issue migration asked migration of
people from one world to another and the
capacity of nation-states committed at
least notionally to ideals of democracy
on to absorb and to integrate and to
make full citizen participants in
society of people who come from places
different parts of the world and whose
backgrounds cultural origins sometimes
don't fit in as well and we might get to
the hostess aside that as we know is it
is a challenge for for Western societies
for work
silent and energy for societies all
around the world for a long time and
it's become a particularly acute issue
in recent decades that's one that many
countries including the United States
and France almost of all faiths now the
question is long and its continuing
encounter with the West with Western
societies with particularly
to France this is a topic that's taken
on particular residence in your policy
world and global policy world in the
last couple of years last decade in
particular and that encounter something
that means clear head focused attention
from scholars from policy experts and so
I think that the the issues that can
feeling with our tremendous importance
here a tremendous importance to Siva and
to Colombia and I know that having done
some work myself on the comparisons of a
race and religion and integration policy
in the United States and France on other
countries but this is not an easy task
it but putting on my social science
active or
essential task we need to understand
both differences and similarities
between these two countries and other
countries need to understand what we can
learn about particular challenges that
the United States faces that France
faces that other individual country
space in confronting these issues and we
also need to learn by juxtaposing
different kinds of systems with facing
similar challenges you need to learn
what we can understand that a more
general level more abstract a more
across national level about the
challenges of configuration and religion
and migration across across these
countries so I don't want to say much
more since I don't even have a lot of
work to do today and so on behalf of the
school and my boss themes on cuts were
that were welcome you to see but I wish
you a great day and afternoon to the
chair
the first fellow Muslim is industry who
sings undersea according to a set
European integration in France Britain
and Germany comparing the same attitude
to the accommodations of Muslim
religious practices and teaching in
public schools public funding for
Islamic schools and the construction of
mosques Britain has been the most
accommodating of missing two strikes
France the most hostile pillar and
generally in between the main
explanation for this according to the
authors to effexor and Christopher
chakra these exacting pre-existing state
Church relations one set of questions
raised in this panel is what extent
those nations effectively incorporation
of Muslims in the United States and
France in other word this France gracias
secularism make us winning accommodate
nuisance and the United States which is
characterized by a more friendly
separation between church and state side
professor 7 this parallel also examined
the various forum in which safe
institutions and do some community
leaders are engage in order
in the aftermath of September's 11
Weston said halfway war on using
extremists evaluations but at the same
time they have delivered to promote the
hood nuisance and a more work has group
who've already called liberal sub
progressive serve or hundreds are in the
process of bridge building between their
polar regions and the host society whose
team intellectuals have been in the
forefront in rethinking Islam for the
first twenty first century for the whole
event per second as we argued by some
families they have emphasized the common
Abrahamic heritage of Judaism
Christianity Islam promote you could
mention with AC are beneficial for the
scene integration the question of new
Jewish students homes in minorities in
the West inner took a taqueria is at the
heart of the question of Houston
integration in Ireland forretress
perience of minorities for Muslims
living in the West har har Adar one is a
leading different public inspection and
the chairman of the fifth Council of
North America sighs various reasons why
the Islamic jurisprudence inherited from
the old school the old Medina is
unsuitable for Muslim communities living
in the West day and I want to make
mutations addition of body open the cold
Muslims according to whom were not used
sequin live revolution or justice in the
non-muslim whales citizenship are the
contract is understood today was the no
they were no established criteria for
gaining citizenship in another country
the ancient world had no concern or
experience of international war and
diplomatic convention applies in most
countries to protect migrant the
rationale of power range supreme umpires
no new embarrassing you know frontiers
and there are real stopped advancing
only when the terrain will benefit our
predecessors did not experience the team
the closely interconnected world we live
within its day the fifth of monthly that
is the jurisprudence of country was then
recovered dictated by the time but what
is needed today is reduced millions of
resistance and I closeable so why do you
think that losing minorities can do
better today without the chip the
disappearance born for a culture of
conflict and that the elaboration of a
new clip for nearly students must not be
an exercise of the Islamic purist as has
been the case in the past rather it
requires input from experts from
different disciplines of the modern
social scientists who can work with
religious juries to elaborate a
jurisprudence started open G heartily
interpretation and debated and such such
a students may even inspire us the
majority the individual promote in Islam
for the 21st century that is compatible
with all the nerves of Tolerance gender
justice and democracy is not just
important for minorities talent
consenting those who were to respond to
the rifle study the names he's in 47
careful thus the trade development I
mentioned earlier are closely
interrelated and approach which places I
request
the second panel Muslims and public
sphere importantly shaken in Spanish the
diversity and complexity of what has
been called Connecticut Sam Morrison see
the film experts have argued that
although Islamism was very hidden in the
aftermath of a starting evolution he had
to climb or fail by the late 20th
century and notable among them are chief
kevin is a jihad texting star or a walk
bailiff went to be some desire to lead
in French assigns the trajectory of
political asylum in the United States
and France is addressed by two papers in
this panel a show that political studies
nigel morality neither one will be
Signori mutual alongside hard- there is
growing majority of service offering a
new understanding of stuff they have
joined worms and other organic
intellectuals to promote the new form of
political engagement of uses in Western
societies remarkable remember our guru
singh button OOP you nearly sunset in my
earlier and having have become the most
transactions are nice people and the
charger to the consumer in American
artists are vulnerable interesting fella
moderation and constructive engagement
are one side of the story other side is
criticism or be throwing many attractive
than you are I've been critical of
western states policies
as well as a failure to accommodate the
needs at home the search for artists
colony connection has been a way for
someone's DeMuth experiencing variance
would truly build ourselves a number of
them have been rolling in starting
institution of learning or drunken civic
groups created by rusev actor's voice
inside position on most issues that
there was cited spaces for critique said
failure to automotive needs the third
parent gender in generational relations
the set of questions raised in his
finalists what happened to gender and
generational relations after migration
of Saturn Gouda Mirren succeeding with
producing home and Eleanor from their
whole society how does an average
outside the ripple effect inherited
general the second set of questions
deeds with the transmission of identity
the next generation a very good question
that has out is the first generation
networks which immigrant children are
socialized to their ethnic groups and
the actors entrusted with the
responsibility to inculcate Kendall
neurons are at residence other people
presented here corporal gender and
generational issues among the grinder
ethnic Muslims including Turks Arab
states audience the first in a standard
race ethnicity MC station as already
mentioned a sizable second generation of
misleading
unlike their immigrant parents worst of
this you were born in involved the
nationality of their wishes cookies but
are the film everything is Photoshop
nationality the police guarantee or
citizenship rights race and religion can
be reasons for exclusion Australian both
countries are the questions raised our
what extent residential segregation DS
and obstacle in division are there
similarities between residential
segregation in French out ECT staff all
year and American universities I hope
that the importance of the themes and
the bread and intermarriage of the
papers discussed today in general
questions and criticism that will now
build a coherent framework of comparison
of rushing to the United States and
France in the early 21st century and
thanks again for attending any his
conference and we hope that you stay all
day and without a good you and we now
have the torch to Rebecca of the
migration was a group who will introduce
professor
this is a vibration recording group i'm
here to introduce dr. sulemani Sheriff
Dan who's professor in the Department of
French and publish philosophy here at
Columbia University his research
research is focused on the history of
philosophy and logic Islamic philosophy
african philosophy and literature he
received his academic training at france
whose former fellow at the ecole normale
superior resetting with Balthazar and
Ariza and who received both of bachelors
and Doctorate degrees at the University
of Paris prior to teaching at Columbia
professes en was a vice dean and a
professor in the philosophy department
at the University to cart Senegal and he
was also professor at the department of
philosophy and religion at Northwestern
University his many publications include
a study of George pools algebra of logic
a study of the Indian poet and
philosopher Muhammad Iqbal and his most
recent publications look through a study
of Leopold cigar and a book title come
on philosophy
Islam with traces the development of
philosophy so please give a warm welcome
to a dark silly mamash Indian thank you
very much Rebecca Rebecca staff meetings
about this panel of scholars who are
going to introduce us to a challenge
represented by an integration of Islam
in Western as announced by guzmn come
earlier the toppings are those this
integration and I just realized that all
the panelists in some kind of military
discipline have a line of cells
according to the order in which they are
going to speak so academia is infused
with military spirit we did not know so
which means that our first speaker would
be Ahmed clothes and my extreme right
the code is someone with a BA from the
University wonderful scholar of the
University who is now assistant
political science in San Diego State
University and his study will be
secularism state policies and Muslims
comparing tracks and relaxes it's good
on you like at Colonia well work on
Concord of settlers must be deeply
inspired for supper
its presence in this time I wish I
wasn't a presentation powerpoint when we
talk about this thing's in France and
United States first thing to do is to
look at the demography mr. population in
workplaces and it's the contested issue
because the number of Muslims in the
United States it's a very controversial
thing according to some public service
ratio is male or less than zero
so some public service gives the number
less than 2 million and I put the range
of three to seven because President
Obama is speech in Cairo given number
seven minutes 0 input maximum level and
according to 327 million it's constant
one to two percent in France it's almost
the same four to five kidding but the
person is much hundred seventy eight
percent if we look at some institutional
data to understand the public visibility
of these two populations the number of
most may seem shy an inference but it is
directed linked to the fact that by most
inference we mean something there's
small spaces and if you look at the
person which is twelve percent of almost
United States has very big size more
than five hundred and some of them being
with 5,000 people whereas in friends
only for yourself but they like this so
those who visit Paris on Friday traders
prime
evidence they want about the people
praying on streets because of the lack
of sufficient number of most whereas in
a united states that are big mosque in
different cities but at this scientific
ladies are documented but if you look at
two other criteria the number of islamic
school and the state policies toward
whistle has scars on schools there's a
big difference more about 400 schools of
375 in the united states and only three
in France because of bureaucratic
restrictions because of the difficulty
to find their privates was in France
when it comes to Catholic schools which
constitute twenty percent of all
students in Prince their budgets about
eighty percent for many comes from state
money as so far not the case for Islamic
schools therefore they have financial
travel tease when nastes bureaucratic
restrictions may be are over there for
today there are hundreds of is our
schools and if you look at the legal
status for the Legal Foundation has been
and now the proposed for cabin our key
issue in Fresno
don't have such policies in the United
States beyond this has been a number of
Islamic schools if you look at the
American public sphere there is a
certain level of Houston visibility so
you are seeing present obama at what
house in ramadan if their inner in which
then has skirt you're picturing then at
the bottom you have the US post service
commemorating stand for the eat the
muslim all days and the next to it you
see an Muslim chaplain namely plus the
hunter and then he gave the opening
prayer speech in the congress last night
so this kind of public visibility of
islam is hard to see to be seen in the
French public sphere why why are muslims
have why are the Muslims have more
opportunities in the United States to
express their religiosity the bar there
are less restrictions in the American
public spheres tour distance from the
visibility there are alternative
explanations one alternative is that
Muslims in France constitute a higher
proportion seven to eight percent
therefore some policymakers some public
figures think
there's so much concern about it and try
to restrict the potential threat in this
so if you look at the number of missing
girls wearing headscarf which was a big
debate in France from eighteen ninety
nine to two thousand four they cost to
the base than 1,500 so they are not a
big threat in terms of number negligible
number if you look at Muslims in France
whether they are pious radical Islamists
or in terms of affiliation with Islam
they are not different from the French
people why because the church attendance
and were Catholic French people are ten
percent and most offenders of wisdom
French tempers are saying very very
secure as people in terms of Muslims in
Europe French music seems to be the most
secular as a less religious then not a
big trade for an Islamic perspective and
then maybe isn't because of the fact
that listings in the united states are
much well represented in Congress in the
local political administration therefore
they lobby and they gave you they get
certain rights whereas in France they
are not where I presenting politics
that's the expander is difference
between you two is this so not tense
please not work because if you look at
boosting
education almost the same because in the
United States there's one with some
senator only to Congress people in the
house zero governor and only four state
legislature out of more than 7,000 and
in France to North African virgin
senators 0 deputy so in all cases
because of the majoritarian election
system single district system and also
because of certain public concern about
ustream identities which stems are not
well represented and the representation
doesn't explain the difference between
the two cases and then is this because
of Islamophobia what do we mean by some
according to a British NGO running mate
trust there are many compliments of
Islamic for it Islam be seen as
monologue static unchangeable separate
and other it doesn't have values in
common what it's seen as barbara
purcell's person threatening everything
so it's hard to believe all of them but
if you leave something thank you it has
several components so we have this kind
of perspectives in America more French
public sphere of popular players remain
largely s because in the United States
according to public service three groups
have certain negative stereotypes a
taste Mormons Anderson's right and if
people are asked whether they could both
work
the majority has raised know if you look
at the French public service so
definitely the concerns about Islam or
at least Islamism it's very deep in the
Frenchman memory starting with shots of
the rola 732 war between the wisdom 10
to a ship from Spain and the Battle of
Tours where the French Army's optimist
in control of Europe point back to the
colonial era the colonization of Algeria
and then to the recent immigrants coming
to France and in bar 2002 elections in
the presidential election the far right
yanmega pants party from nationality 17
person of words he would get even higher
than software specialist Prime Minister
Josephine's sixteen percent and then it
shows that there certain level of public
concern of Muslims mom a call
Islamophobia there is very various
social scientific analysis to show that
to have a microwave in name and just in
background reduce your chance of finding
a good job even with the same cv of
every
name because of this concern so
does that explain difference between
United States entrance there is nowhere
because in both countries you have some
hope school in the United States we have
certain evangelical jumping the TV's 700
clubs and others and then what explained
it I would argue that the main factor
that define the two cases is the two
types of ideologies psychologist in one
case in friends the Dorian's version of
secularism is what I call assertive
secularism according to which the state
is supposed to play a certain role when
as in the United States the dominant
version of sickness miss passive sectors
in which the state is supposed to play
at passable in a sort of secularism
state right excluding engine from box
wait and make it a private issue whereas
in the back passive secularism of the
pastor signal the state doesn't have
such as social engineering project it
doesn't create a privatized illusion it
just follow rates and I
visit of religion but the countries are
not monolithic a massive effort to save
them instead there are always
ideological struggle between groups in
each of the two chases so in the United
States the debate is between two types
of passive circulars not two
interpretations of it one is the
separation is understanding of master
sector which requires a Jeffersonian or
separation between church and state and
in the Supreme Court the separations
judges were coming from 1940s until very
recently and the recent accommodations
gained five verses for majority able to
nourish appointments according to
accommodations there should not be a
wall of separation certain entanglements
between church and state are fine as
long as the state does not favor one
single religion and expense of others so
when you look at the separations vs.
accommodation debating Venus is when I
conduct interviews with they represent
Association level I realized that both
sides actually opposed and French type
has scarred man why because disagreement
within these two groups is about the
establishment course whether religious
establish with the public prayer with a
certain level of state recognition of
religion with ten commandments and other
things when it comes to individual
velocity expression of religious faith
they have a certain level of agreement
there for free exercise clause is not a
big issue between them and in the
American legal system based on massive
seculars mo or can not single out all
religions for one single religion in
terms of religion religious symbols
therefore the French ban on all
religious symbols is it doesn't have any
legal basis in the u.s. it's because you
cannot prohibit a single based on the
mere fact that it's religious you should
have some very general concerns such as
held order for the golden or security
even in the conditions where you have
general reason for imposing a
prohibition religious groups in the
United States may be exempt from general
and for example the u.s. department they
issued the principle that the pictures
in the passport should be bear hat you
are not
we're anything but they say unless it's
more for religious purposes therefore
they put an exemption would so there are
lists of cases for example the Amish
case where the Amish haven't applied to
the Supreme Court away from the
requirement of student at tennis and
then the court decided that based on
their religious beliefs and practices
the Amish society is exempt from sending
their children to school after eighth
grade there is a recent debate on in the
a versatile in the symmetries of 1990
it's a very important case to show the
difference between us and french
understanding of signals my legal
principles so one name two American with
his white friend in Morton they use po10
which is at mark how to selling a drug
and ironically they were working for a
private anti drug rehabilitation center
and then at the senator fired them for
you things are and then they say we use
it as religious purposes it was all
religious ritual well the one is not
Native American said that I converted to
new technology and then the debate was
that according to majority of the
Supreme Court it was Farnsworth Oracle
state to put it in a state law that drug
is prohibited unless you use it for
religious purposes but since the Oregon
State didn't do it us 25 or maybe more
than half of the other states still
there is no constitutional exemption for
dinner views and then the minority
say no even if the Oregon State with an
acceptance in the state law still there
is a constitutional protection of
religious practices therefore these
gentlemen's using religious ceremonies
should not be fired so even at test
level the American legal system protect
and support simples and purposes and it
is impossible to think about single and
odds which is similar when it comes to
the French case the debate is between
two types of secularism handsome answer
given the local language like sticking
combine is the premier so and if you
look at the understanding of secularism
of the race the comp a very much
assertive secularism religion should
guard public sphere and his suicide
debated it for 15 years at the end the
combative settlers or assertive signals
into
nology won the debate and then they push
the bed and pass it in Parliament
because they had about seventy percent
of public support where is thirty
percent of French public oppose demand
seventy percent supported event so then
the next question what makes or let me
what makes their search of secular is
powerful because when it comes to the
issues on Catholic schools the public
almost evenly divided fifty-fifty but
when it comes to Islam there are certain
sectors had a new ally which is the sum
of all right so in the headscarf debate
we see the emergence of a new coalition
so to all enemies to left and right wing
enemies come together assertive signal
smart and some of the immigrant rights
to men has burst the multi cultures that
the multicultural right came together to
support a more liberal new understanding
of settlers in my own passive settlers
and if you look at the discourses for
the proband side there are what
republican a fabulous discourses the
public school should unify the
homogenized differences should be let
out the husker
a female submission and object operation
whereas an time then cognition argue
that it's the public school should not
tolerate should color diversity should
not discriminate and oscar has multiple
meanings parallel or Brotherhood
operation is not only mean Master so
then the question is why is a start of
sickness in Bamiyan in France where as
passive signal is the WT geology in the
United States to explain it I look at
the historical origins and especially
the presence or absence of an ASEAN
regime so the unseen regime refers the
existence of a monarchy and a hegemonic
religion and the cooperation between the
monarchy regiment religion against the
Republican moments and by the
Republicans challenge and defeat the
monarchy they also target religious
hegemony because they sewed into
schedule me as an ally of the old regime
good on our CEO regime so in case of
like friends to Mexico Spain personal
Soviet Union there was a Nazi regime
before the republican era therefore the
Republicans were
political in countries that there was no
Republican transition the monarchy image
of occlusions are near and contemporary
they announce it asada they are still
contemporary but in the future that it
may become a Nazi regime in some cases
no more like a dramatic religion
religion alliance like in some cases
more testimonials and in the case of
United States with some similar exit
other examples there was neither Pokemon
Aquino a joke religion there were
multiple Protestant denomination with an
under for a crown British crown and then
it didn't consider incineration when i
presently some people bring the issue of
the british one gram + England Church of
England American church actually it's
really support idea once in a while
because since Anglican Church supported
the British Warren kid during the
colonial period right after the
Revolution many of its did they priestly
imprison to the next hour left the
country they had changed the name of the
church and that many of the former stop
going and in all southern colonies and
then became state and local church
so really the local does the minimum
example of on synergy also burned in the
American DC but in the larger picture
that was not a nationwide outage in
there for Jefferson medicine and other
founding fathers are good quantum
rationals were not anti-clerical and the
Avenger cooks like Isaac bacon and some
other Protestant leaders were by and
large open value of separation because
if there if there are 20 different
denominations your denominations chance
of being established is one out of 20
and the other at connecticut's someone
else the nomination becomes established
nineteen on three therefore it is at the
second best choice for you to see a
church-state separation in the federal
and state level but in france the
republicans are monarchies had a severe
conflict almost your son game because
the Catholic conservative supporting
monarchy they didn't want to see a
separation you know they want to keep
the French chattering establishment
whereas the Republicans channel all the
monarchy and the catalyst option there
for a purist certain anti political
reforms especially nature republic so
people
citing important of the promotional 1789
but from the self promotion to the
turkey but with many things change
Beck's and force always but it was a
lead the third republic which really
kind and establish secularism from 1876
2 9006 you see the change of the numbers
of the catholic schools and in catholic
to teachers and students in Catholic
schools and the sharp decline was not a
simple result of societal demand and
free market know it was a purposeful
action by the republican secular
governments and Parliament's certain
lost a pass tonight or 190 0 for a 1905
and they expelled certain Catholic
school principals and teachers and try
to eliminate Jesuits and some other
Catholics groups and the result is the
decline of Catholic infants in education
and rise of alternative public sector
school system so if I summarize the mall
argument in three minutes the presence
or absence of counsel regime in the
French the apt presence in an American
example the absence of Thomson regime
led to the dominance of a circle
security
some passive citizen in the United
States but obviously for the last two
centuries many things change in the
United States for example secularism
initially man state neutrality towards
all Protestant denominations especially
for the 19th century there was kind of
cultural semi establish more Protestants
but by the market rally 1920s and had
the prohibition and eternity change
Protestantism disestablish but by 1950s
immune established emerged with monitors
anti-communist McCarthy era then eyes
another time and then 1960s came Supreme
Court which decision as prohibition of
bible reading and prayer in schools also
he's established to volunteer stick
establishment and now is the debating
United States to in checkers of the Jews
and Catholics integrated to social
political system in the United States by
1930s 40s 50s 60s and today for example
look at the Supreme Court six judges are
Catholics to choose and only one per
test analyst 93 years golden will resign
soon with similar but it really showed
that Catholics and Jews really became
very much center of the support
consistent and now the debate is
integrating 80s the Mystics and the
Mormons when it comes to friends yes it
was anti-catholic in the
public but it was moderated so the Vichy
experience part ways the dramatical but
after that with the Deborah of 1959 the
cat the French state recognizes started
to fund Catholic schools and then there
have been kind of equilibrium in France
when it comes to Catholicism and
secularism is much more moderate but
when it comes to Islam assertive secular
really remember they're all canticle
political times and now they have a new
allies some lobsters for rice and the
combination of these two groups resulted
in shorter restriction or mr. such as
has come back so although the man was
not a scarf or develop religious symbols
but it's really know as the British
saying that the law that prohibits
sleeping on the bridge is equal to apply
to everyone or rich and poor rich be
water under the bridge so 46 missing the
test car and 36 are expelled there is a
zero Christian cross the road you should
keep up and the combination of the
dominance secular ideology with certain
cooperation of Alliance and debates
among video two groups web certain
policies and we'll see the result of
more inclusion on system united states
whereas more exclusionary policies
inference
our next speaker is jazzy professor of
sociology at John Jay College she's a
component of the three minute system and
he's talking me on Western Islam
andalusia and other crops of a key in my
presentation I am going to focus on some
of the ways in which Muslims in the West
special goes in in the u.s. try to under
exclusion how do they integrated some
other the discursive strategies that
they employ making me sound America
Iranian Islam Western so I have chosen
to highlight now the second generation
and convert your sins frequently
distinguish between culturalism and true
Islam or more generally between culture
and religion I always find this
distinction to be a powerful discursive
device it allows them to dissociate what
they consider the pure Islam or the
essence of religion from the cultural
norms and practices associated with a
religious system women criticizing the
patriarchal practices of not so
religious immigrant parents or a young
human predicament the south yarra in
policy of not allowing
to drive cars are just two examples this
eminent critic is not unique to American
Muslims Islam has crossed many cultural
boundaries to such constant
reinterpretation and this is a point
that most of the current calls for
reform in some synchronous my research
on Islam in America has shown me that
context considerably skews the contact
this of course is not used to students
also charge of knowledge or adherence to
the constructionist view of reality but
here I would like to draw attention to
something more specific Islam is not
revealed a new in America it draws on
the same vocabulary of Islamic images
and symbols available everywhere but it
emphasizes different version of that
were carefully normal concepts are
revitalized while some active elements
may put to sleep this happens at an
unconscious level in response to the
social and historical environment that
he was on examples the figure of Abraham
who is unavoidably present in Houston
ritual practices but does it autoplay a
central place interesting imagination or
in wishing self-perception gains and
traveling in American culture in a
similar brain many Muslims would say
that the legacy of nursing Spain doesn't
necessarily represent
I find of Muslim religious history for
many reasons certainly the otterbox it
came very well be seen as a period of
degeneration not with those of Muslims
do not value the pluralism and religious
tolerance of the period but because that
dimension is out there any criteria
increasing contact zones whether in
America or elsewhere such elements gain
new relevance and importance people who
know parallels between the frontier
cultures of Western Islam then it was
saying now it is europe and america as
if they receive all of Andalusia had
taken off from medieval times and landed
in contemporary America so inclusive
educational center in Virginia of itself
university of Cordova in a multimedia
company a subdivision of the Xavier
Institute in California is named all
control actions Bruce teen parents in
American League liaisons Ibrahim Joseph
Adam and Eve daughters mary m and Sarah
but not haha garages so he might
discussion today I explored the truth
rolls over madness now we're such
appropriation happens one of them is
this new emphasis on other Lucia as both
a precursor of mission identity in us
and a golden age of Lucy
multiculturalism and the other truck is
the unprecedented emphasis on Abraham as
a common ancestor
Islam and other Western religions to
proceed I need to clarify a concept i
use in the title of my presentation that
is western Islam it's a phenomenal
question Islam it evolves out of
interaction with the Western political
and cultural environment thus like any
other articulations of Islam it is
historical it suppresses certain
elements of Islam and highlights others
for example the motions of jihad or
garbled heart acquire new meanings or
face marginalization Western Islam disc
release by Muslims in Europe and America
here of course I'm not using a
theological motion of Islam but a
sociological regardless of the universe
out of its message Islam inhabits
various cultures and movements in time
and styles of expression therefore one
can legitimately speak of Americanism or
Europe any summer as a lot of people
week it reflects the tastes concerns
comforts and anxieties of Muslims living
in the West as religious minorities I
already mentioned the distinction
between religion and culture in this
distinction religious stands for an
ahistorical pure religion while culture
refers to the historical and cultural
forms has taken in a given society often
deployed against the culturally
incongruent
in missing practices in America it
inserts a distance between religion and
various cultures in Islam those cultures
open happen to be those of Middle East
Africa or South Asia Anderson community
leader in Detroit once Toby many people
miss a culture or religion take for
instance in Saudi Arabia women don't
drive cars well the Dhamma say women
can't drive cars or did saudi amend say
that women can't drive guards such a
distinction opens the possibility
morning practices and new
interpretations of religion without
undermining the continuity and the
integrity of islam in this search for
the right form of islam islam exhaust
historical forms it has taken in
different places and remains
uncontaminated by the problematic
aspects of specific cultures so cultures
are amended in the name of pure religion
and since religion can be found nowhere
without a cultural form this evangeline
is ultimately done for the sake of in
facilitating a institution and
inhabitation of any culture in its
various forms so if you associate
yourself from let's say Egyptian culture
or solving culture and you agree
associate religion pure Islam within
American tour it settles in in any form
so it is emergent version or
articulation of Islam we see a strong
interest and emphasis on twisting Spain
despite a very long time portal yet and
cultural difference why you which seems
in
tend to incorporate new sim Spain as an
exemplary era my answer is because
receive Spain offers Muslims in America
and in Europe a set of identity forming
discursive laws such tools include
history which means Islam Islam new
familiarity which means your sins are
not strangers and acceptability which
means the sum is not undemocratic let me
explain further already history
Christine presence in the West is not
limited to recent integration we are
part of it european astray and Western
civilization we were here we are here we
belong here that's the message that the
use of course in Spain our games second
one familiarity it says we are all
children of Abraham we have a history of
coexistence and toleration goosing Spain
offers this rare slice of history when
she wanna taste it religion sleep
together in a considerable the to your
peace and harmony the Western
civilization is not simply too narrow
Christian it is you know Christian
Islamic or Abraham
except the property well his son is
fully compatible with democracy if
contemporary missing countries suggest
otherwise it is because of the garage
that's the message that this notion
keeps okay it's not me protective so the
fact that Islam can be pluralistic and
multi cultural is proven by the
historical example of Christian Spain
there for contemporary Western
democracies should be realistic
realistic with respect to the regime's
in the image and should offer the lessee
around the multi-cultural take the
effort of reaching down to Andalusia or
missing Spain is similar to earlier
african-american efforts to reach a
fluid copia European civilization in
this way inject history and cultural
death into the colonized and
marginalized web identity in the case of
African Americans ok so far more
children of immigrants second-generation
regimes which is go back to the savage
Spain to give their pluralism and
relevance today with some identity in
the Western context so that I
chronically we can say that the uses of
Islamic strain include insistent
insistence on Muslims deep roots from
continuity and Western identity and
synchronically Islamic Spain means
pluralism multiculturalism and a notion
of liberalism so when we fight this
trope very divided people talk about
Muslim Spain finding in public lectures
by popular speakers in convert
narratives of self-identity and
increasingly
activities a documentary film about the
lead of comprehensive final cities of
white the rise and fall of Islamic Spain
which came in 2007 was one of the series
was one of a series of recent public the
division offerings that portrayed
Newsome culture truth Americans in a
strikingly positive life fundraising for
the film became a cause clbre among
wealthier and more liberal American
Muslims naturally defiende also drew
considerable criticism from the usual
and perishing suspects now the second
truck is the notion of the idea of
Abraham interfaith activities are so
central to the naturalization of Islam
in America that the search for common
ground effectively leads to a new
emphasis evades will discover you're
both Abraham and Christian Spain they
are respectively theological and
historical links that missions believe
happen four dozen eggs should be
reclaimed rossini vomit in interfaith
dialogue certainly as a longer history
but all activists I have spoken to agree
that 911 had a tremendous impact on
their level of engagement there has been
an explosion of ecumenical event since
nine eleven and
machines are increasingly becoming
visible on the ecumenical Synod
contemporary listen vocabulary draws
heavily on the shared origin of the
three monotheistic religions and can be
safely summarized as Abrahamic discourse
such encounters intervent encounters
elevate one element of missing identity
to a central position the idea of
Abraham as father of the three more
patient religions they share a faith
with a common belief in God prophets
revelation and divinely made mandated
community and moral responsibility while
Jews and Christians trace their lineage
to Abraham through Isaac recent true so
true Ishmael so as visitors approach the
entrance of the Unity Center a rich
suburban mosque in Detroit the first
thing they see is a rock inscribed with
a verse from the Quran and the verse is
an exclusive statement of Islam as an
Abrahamic religion you don't find
anything of this nature in
environment the verse says say we have
believed in God and in what was revealed
to us and what was revealed to Abraham
Ishmael Isaac Jacob and the descendants
and in what was given to Moses and Jesus
and to the profits from their rope we
make no distinction between any of them
and we are missing some submit including
that's the worse now this is emphasis on
Abraham I want them to establish a
relationship of kinship with dominant
religious identity in the US and this is
a claim 2 t-shirts it's not a
pluralistic demand for acceptance it is
almost a tribal of little or inclusion
and this is partly responsible to make
additional 911s so it's partly a
response to the Empire simple sentiment
and political
now as mrs. engage in interfaith
dialogue they step into the public
square where there is a specific for me
to which every particular religion is
held by an art and culture and that form
is American civil religion scholars of
the urban culture and our military
identity is no longer anchored in
Christianity but rather in a more
generic mystic civil religion this
religion is characterized by belief in
God respect for difference and the
belief that religion is a matter of
individual choice one way receive it to
Frank activists consciously or not maybe
some an American religion is fed up the
ecumenical mode of speech Islam is
detached from its earlier forms what we
previously called culturally son the
process of pouring Islam into its new
mall in Sumerian form gives rise to two
kinds of ecumenism two kinds of
universalism externally it neutralizes
the differences between e 7 30 Christian
tradition and internally it undermines
internal divisions among ethnic racial
and sectarian lines so in essence music
as Muslims engaging interpret activities
they come to appreciate their own
differences between Sunnis and Shias our
college students groan efforts to bring
together to me that they call it sushi
so it has a more domestic internal of
benefit less than engaging in efforts of
now the figure of Abraham who doesn't
occupy a central place in mission
culture in their conventional settings
gains problems against a minority
context he is one of the few common
threads that stretch through which is
something every American or Western
imagination and find a foothold of
legitimacy he designed it had to be race
differences in the public mind by
assimilating distance into the category
of mo Abrahamic believer public public
was for the power used this therefore if
the post-world war two discourse of
judeo-christianity along the
Christianization or normalization of
jews ever having this course in the post
9-11 error response to a comparable
boosting demand for Christianization or
normalization via inclusion kinship and
commonality of uses now in Western
societies machines are immigrant
minorities and they face a challenge of
articulating a profile of Islam that is
West in Islam that is acceptable to the
majority status in the contact zone
between the Sun and appreciated which
sims 3
to various drops of community here I
have highlighted the two most important
ones the White Sox missing spain and the
discourse of Abraham both rusev Spain
and Abraham allowed the second
generation and convert Muslims in your
American societies to produce any sum
that legitimately feel at home in
Western cultures thank you and those are
alien pictures of Muslim communities and
as a French authorities as well as a
principal embodiment of Islamic
Authority particularly as a local level
the first part of my writing
contribution summarize the condition in
which sister Sarah world of Imams about
inference a president I present form a
sociological interview the chief says
observable tutoring as immigrant workers
of Muslim face and how they became along
with their families cilantro rice into
French society I also described
principal facets of the human world
however my cook my oral communication
will focus on the second part of my
article a section dedicated to the study
of the historical innings between the
French state and turkey moms since the
1990s I will focus on the recent years
when the French States has taken to a
state of the issue of humans with the
aim of influencing the definition of
Islam finally confidential for as long
as was managed by the Ministry of
Walker in the 1970s this file credit he
became more significant during the 1980s
the context of the state reflection was
a complete debates on the need to
integrate immigrants which in the case
of the Muslim religious notably produces
the discourse on the need to update most
emotion in relation to this case with
the burner history on French soil
however Solomon amendment only approach
is a question of historical the meaning
of correcting its materialism bullet and
Marie indeed germs lack of cultural
center obsessive of representation
absence of religious broadcast on public
channels etc so animate remains
similarly concerns with little media
attention the situation changed
radically from the early 1990s Islam and
Muslim motion was considered as a
sensitive issue in French arraignment
advances because of a societal historic
old
marked by the city conflict energy
indeed in this context agent of the
interior ministry focused on the
possible fallout in France on the rise
of opposition and political Islam
reasons and how women in Muslim world
and particularly in North Africa a first
step of this increased focus was the
development of the surveillance of Imam
Zaman and the result is a question of
Islamic Muslim worship it can say from
the perspective of sick of security by
the French state appearances a security
perspective which frequently happens in
the interior ministry a cave from the
1990s well starting with the second term
of characters an entire minister this
killing dimension fundamentally straight
i quote claim to the minute claim to
eliminate friends in reference to this
race to state according to the consular
of the minister should under one and
follow the rise of I quote whatever
Allah and Islam well integrated into
French society and quote and under other
pan i codm fight against the development
of wireless key with imam fridge
fundamentalism intolerance and violence
and of god imagine doing clear drugs 10
years excavation became walmart doing
that of John passport who ordered the
first survey
of south of the motion so surveillance
again already increased again is kill me
during derby the women date following
the wave of attacks of terrorist attacks
in France in 1995 which terminated in
the bonding of the error between in
Paris indeed the environment of Cal Cal
Cal in this act of violence a human born
in Algeria but having burner interlayer
impor I work areas and we came Islam is
imprisoned reinforced so he had James of
the Interior Ministry suspicion towards
immigrants clearly represented by
eminent friends through the
generalization of surveillance of him
examined the page member france any
emotional always take information
service which has no us equivalent at NC
are given to task by the entire history
of identifying excuse me firstly all
attempt by the amount to bring thy
service political speeches and conflict
into french re and secondly any other
names of poor use from so-called
difficult urban neighborhood to send in
form of religious radicalism and the
confluence of the logic of maintaining
public order on the one hand and on the
other hand a matrix of order debates
around the integration of foreigner
among party at 77 from
location of the agent of the state of
the French state burst into the field of
the state's concern in the 1990s a
single step of the scene Chris Rogers
was a development for the question of
his life in of France and the appearance
of a different metrics of the state
discourse of the month until the end of
the 1990s French Estonia's French
authorities accepted the fact that
Muslim wash it was a sincerity total at
the local level with the creation of the
new teachers of Israeli gas station
largely independent from each other in
the subsequent decade the development of
oppositional Islamic Islam and it's
possible extension on French soil gross
details with mr. to make so the
presentation and organization of Muslim
ocean friends as a complete program
requirement state intervention billions
of assess the vicissitude of party
politics this is way to rationalize the
structure of French civil civil religion
in public line input i justified either
need to favor the emergence of Islam a
la francaise an expression there miss
white to listing project so first openly
acknowledged consists in guaranteeing
reduce the quality in the country I
improving the condition of
motion in France and this made the legal
definition of security and easy so
second less covered by the media risotto
less recognized officially since it does
not participate in the framework of
secularism aimed to circumscribes with
the state of our choice of religion
which at mercy is a source of news
concerns now as address archive survives
have turned by the entire ministry to
try influence of creation of a central
representative body for muslim worship
are also a compiled by the
institutionalization of a pretty state
discourse of him al as a reference
figures is men gradually come to present
for the encouragement of class Bravo a
de-esser program supposedly post by the
Muslim religion in France or a possible
diffusion-limited for more liberal Islam
model and I'm annotated too fragile
sites in the face of them for any man
presented and notified in Nicaragua so
into entire ministry as are the best the
order of ipod outdated tariqa training
at worst a loving Earl I could again
mark Islamic tendency and the other case
always incomparable speaking French and
understandings with problem a few
strange people really neighborhood the
belief arrested in amount that
yeah ratio of imam would be undertaken
so as to promote a friendship or failing
that the Francophonie man mr. alien
friends another word for the lighting
ideas amongst policy or provide a
crucial place in two separate
territories switched an agenda of the
state of the French state they find any
plan to correct certificate supposedly
definitely both either Muslim leader in
France indeed as a drunken drivers to
dividers of those filled with shell
explination or were accident in the
united states so foreign in a poorly
integrated of fundamentally
fundamentalist slowly we come into this
course of French agent obviously one of
the case to explain the supposed
dissolution of Islam for the volume of
the front of the book on the sleeves of
French alarm in the great
when trailing motivates become positive
agile of most emotion and the possible
solution to this dislocation well with
the former becomes to recurring travel
east of all the tales or palliative we
supposedly proved the dysfunction of
Muslim worship the letter humble there
is a possibility of what they seem and
Islam a la francaise developed let me
add that if believe does not only become
widespread into division of press before
and the corridor phone and foreign
ministry cancer it is a badass village
by the declaration to the media of India
minister and the representative it's
also tell from the seven alpha 1990s to
be guilty replicative in the French
media which transmit it to the public at
large since the duration slowly
legitimize the idea that the responsibly
that is the responsibility of agilent of
the interior ministry to influence the
profile of minister of these emotional
friends however reforming further in the
description of the model intervention of
the state agent in the tutoring of the
hmmm aight i will be better him to
stress such action to what email can be
anything other than program of
publication in the ability to act
indirectly
remains because of the objective
constraints of the legal constitutional
framework of secularism animal cells in
France at work secularism consists in
the body of the elbow which fix the
legal framework framework for state
agent capacity to interval intervene in
the religious sphere it's defiantly the
nature of the relations the state and
Megan can be really hard with religious
organization also the French state does
not officially recognize any religions
some of his patients nevertheless finds
himself in a position to regulate
religious activity for example numbers
of the some type of all ages 40 caliber
gauge school organization religious
institution to confirm to the chair I
levels of organization stability in the
19th in the 19th or failure of
separation separation of church and
state also members of the police can for
the per chance at this organization are
not sure but I think pretty holder but
since the adoption of the lid of the
1905 so French Republic is known earlier
all right to interfere in the solution
nomination of minister of worship for
the religion represented earnest on its
territory engines agents of the 28th
have had at least until we know legal
right to express an opinion on the
fakeness of a given individual to occupy
such the world serve to the apparent
concordance with a legal firm framework
kicked by secularism silly servant and
political representatives are available
to act is an indirect mania for domain
of food election in which the legal and
political realities of state
intervention cannot be questioned
leading difference was Olivia words of
secularism for with interior minister
and this added her visa to act directly
under the Quitman of him out the
nevertheless device at least three
programs of publication which in the
course of the 1990s aimed to act
immediately on the profile of minister
of Muslim worship not nothing like
friends from the Muslim north
interview is a mission of country that
is a country that we say foreign
missionary the first appearances for
civil crazy humans and Friends consists
in viewing the selection and popular
demand as a specific dimension of
diplomatic relations with the countries
of circle Muslim immigration in other
world so attentive plans before as they
need to operate a bureaucratic resident
westernization of the situation of for
any bombs by unwilling to control of
networks of the country of countries of
origin indeed attempting that the world
among occupied by foreign nationals
leaders of the intelligence to try to
favor loot or status as humanity's
officially guaranteed by the governments
of their countries of origin these first
apparatus little immediate areas
including is now inference as that of
the Elco him i'm referring to a program
will enter our cultural cooperation that
already exists between friends and the
principal hundreds of immigration and
which is supposed to our children of
women to stay close to the parents
Regent kritor it rest on the implicit
idea that the candidates elected by
we preach mr. congruent with the
interests of the government's in place
in those days and the other side of the
same column we not facilitate the
propagation of Islamism in France
furthermore supporting is it
controversial follows India's Ministry
attempts to employ trusted diplomatic
channels capable of keeping the American
cell in shape or even ending residence
in France in case of any problems indeed
conceal our moms are not only in a
dependent situation for the financial
and statutory point of view towards the
diplomatic authorities of their original
countries but they also find ourself
dreams and staying friends Jordan
biologicals 220 which in a daily life
and the evens problem a potential
interpreters for active for agent of the
French state a second process which goes
back to Nuremberg 1919 rest of the
inception of the confidential priscilla
procedure for monitoring visa
application in support of the world of
minister of muslim ocean indeed in a
country in which imagine majority of
Muslim clerics do not process French
nationality the entire ministry
systematically used to the right with
alien friends to try and officially to
select good candidates to the Himalaya
at the expense of advance the second
process was taking also exploitation of
for mineral rights to receive into
extension of the already located sprint
of ellicott technique treatment of four
ways through the frequent use of a drug
circular this measure which probably
affect position and email also is only
in fact under fringe fringes of the
profile of humanity friends is not
visible symbolic usefulness for late
they open history whether the
petitioning Imam are expected or take
more or less don't worry we travel to
carats each of the stage of the
administrative investigation says as
well as a reminder of I bought them to
Twitter foreigner were infringed on the
world of good conduct exposing self
suddenly this process continued
contributes to facilitate his a romantic
identification of foreigners this tre
dici as an immediate advantage for the
state of facilitating the centralization
of the body of information of which the
values administration eSports on one
human and was out to record and possibly
to finish older than behavior Oba Diah
suspected to be deal to be different at
last year ago it less similar agent
agent of the entire ministry to force
open for any man a certain reading of
what women shipping friends in the sense
that all individuals who agree to
subject
to Bianca genomes of identification
partisan indirectly in the symbolic
acknowledgement of these bones more
media tourism to the first to the
certifies can say by idly by agent of
the interior ministry to try to
influence a portion of young officiating
infringement ski to paper out and
supervise projects in ten team to ensure
the training of email alpha cells this
last program is meant to create screw
the educational institutions are
produced in animals the place where
Islamic religious reasoning is adjust to
the filter logic of the French day
formatting good practices and ladies
went away for future teen moms for the
greater had a tissue of the volume of
French society however the creation of
institution institutions that have the
same time qualifying and certifying also
more globally claims to influence the
process for which the world of Imam is
established in friends indeed for the
eight
the st. promoting and directing the
creation of training institution for the
position of the man also stands for the
desire to participate in the object
elation and definition of the right of
entry into element to make an
educational institution the rosemary
means of acceding to innovate it's also
to promise ed listen if not disqualified
other of their alleged amazing having
you that those who wish to enter the
human aid might take to improve
themselves in a given muskie however
most training projects projects start of
suppose supported by the entire ministry
struggled rope and to function
effectively Indian series ii project Z
project started or encouraged I glass
bottle not only experienced financial
difficulties but also our problems to
work with to Britain students and such
training if chair and viewed as an
expensive investment in provision that
is currently poorly regularity while
adapting to introduce official standards
and certifications demeanor of the
apparent reason put in place by the
interior ministry are confirmed with
confronted in practice with a question
of the
medicine really out of it Isaac amount
of attempted short or satisfied as
birthmark I I have consulted and my
university ignore graphic we shall
indicate these public appearances fail
to address the condition of emergence of
a religious authority of which into
every day rest rest rest less an
official titles and certification that
one of the elective affinity forms in
place of worship between an environment
rules or over the time because is
faithful going to have cells of a single
ecclesiastical institution or offer the
organization of the imminent leg that
put in place in 70 g countries of
immigration influence and amounts
audience remains the main parameter by
which the religious legitimacy of a
muslim cleric is evaluated the Santa
Lucia government cannot definitively
marginalized is a successive totally
mom's finding a place of a result of
diverse expectations represented by the
faithful of each maaske indeed not i'll
turn north over the same can guarantee
the success of this quotation whose form
vary depending on the place of worship
but which didn't i determine whether an
email succeed in establishing himself
for in emerging with no escape such a
success with the complex processes of
affinity which love you Gracie can claim
to master
for tables and speak obviously to each
other and stick to you as
d
oh yes please come and use this night in
Central Valley for your comments
in my question is for America have you
encountered any definition by
progressive Muslims or never understand
especially major spokes from a palatable
father addressing major issues like how
the Muslim community sees itself in the
destruction of the global border how'd
the Muslim we need line of defense in
terms of how to date to the divils the
world and have what citizenship rights
mean to them in terms of not just the
rights of defining Islam but also in
terms of rights relating to the Muslim
world and demands they can lay against
the state in which David West last time
I checked had a couple photo published
an article John Esposito and address
book Muslims on the Americanization bath
I didn't see them challenging this
dichotomy of gotta calm down and stop
actually he was just trying to produce
it in a in an American in America
in a way that can be
there is one part of this group
discussing
not so much what I would say a more
left-leaning move within this
progressive trend that we discussed that
very much on visit and well what they
were they want is to of course recognize
their citizenship right they want
decision to Christ nice try the west and
so they will meditate for that right
kind of Allah doesn't seem to be much
more
view definition of is not so the way is
excluding all those who don't know about
Islam to even talk about you wouldn't
say this way so explicitly but is this
course about felt hands that we go
history is very clear on that dr. Kogan
role at him and are important God and
obviously a very much so and so he's
really putting himself in a very
particular class of thinkers but there
is another trend within the
much more attached because she provides
less if it is that says but there is a
discomfort here who is who can speak
about yourself it's because she is not
at all
yes thank you for the session the
recession super short presentation but
verify this figure of ten percent of
practice models in Europe frantic music
I remember well the eve of survey 2007
shows proximately 25% of attendance for
the friday prayer so maybe this time
calibrated Oh what is this ten percent
and from Giles a question completely
with is 3d stores you know we are the
same religion a private religion Sony no
problem second we are here since 14
surgery it is not you and the third one
we are Democrats also Muslim two hits
with two autonomous i think in France I
don't believe in education for instance
inference since the creation of CF CN
french toast of Muslim gods there is a
full discourse for me muslim early
person belonging to the tree that
Muslims are not only Muslims do not see
us only with our difference who can be
possible Plus secular bottom plus a
place
I don't know if there is the same
discourse of multi belonging discourse
anyone among dozens of 38 states
packages you introduced ourselves well
I'm not do it from Saudi diversity
explain what I just came from
actually faster because the real is why
person so beautiful yeah actually that's
a good point sir according to leave at
us young they have a special issue in
center a 2004 in which includes a
specific date about the number of mosca
houston participation and most they
really gave the number five percent in
2004 some great advice from Islam nasty
magazine and I didn't just fight person
because we were not participating Friday
pray therefore try to forget therefore I
use ten percent why because the you if
you multiply five male with bloomin and
main content and then there are three
other sources which are given 10 to 12
person one is the Deborah Commission
report so the present of French
parliament Everett similar to the Stasi
Commission at a commission of a test car
and they gave it ten percent in 2004
then John Jonathan Lawrence and Justin
integrating Islam 2006 they gave ten to
twelve percent and then short cause then
they stomach challenge was ten to twelve
425 but you know public service changed
but I have four different resources in
person so final point Genesis something
to a moment's question about is for my
chest really for a German holodramas
anxious ago and so far in his first
three book I didn't find very
interesting things the only interesting
thing is his critique of the heart are
we stop saying it just drop these
terminologies outdated we have just
grouping schisms and then we are a
minority we are being in students at the
twisting and the recent book has full of
interesting things we can discuss in
research they could separate to my
answer to the question of one's sense of
belonging in france vs in the US I think
of this notion of
nor interior citizens and said anxiety
that is more deeply felt in France
especially by in Europe in general
because that belonging is much more
fragile than it is in us so to reaction
yeah and my point was more specific in
terms of the use of music Islamic Spain
as a legacy what it means other
beneficial
French and integrated ago of banana I
have a question for cement 10 and to
have to light service please syringe or
no forecaster presentation on a llama tu
Reino de palma and especially new
national policies regarding email from
low point of view civil to me witness
more important assertive secular
secularism example of a triangle toward
more assertive secularism would we
witness the birth of places of
secularism so how do you how do you
recall what do you think how do you
estimate new national policies regarding
imams and so if you think that it's a
sign of assertive secularism is it lays
it in probl or lazy T to come back to
server to witness a nominee of the
trains casert if train or to the
contrary the girls of the new pattern of
our country under so I architect what
your opinion too yes the dialogue with
Oh
yeah we'll try to translate this is also
absolutely fresh pasta specifically
travelers with mostly Chicago's like a
stroke himself wonder you're all so good
here i'ma holla at least organized she
still didn't elicit this Alphonse on
Gallagher who's it's either visually TGT
increase in to see you too nervous to
eat skipper so the wrong so you won't
say I discovers universality special
special she was the moment on stickam
said Lucas mosquito area as Christina
least efficient procurement concept I
come back into the city it was good for
sure do something suggest we cut
collectibility presario most basic level
kalamatas a secure
so dirty to me probably 184 sales really
need right here are not contain passion
particular tony sirico to monaco olivier
awards I met once in a certain box there
were google target we do pokemon x 0
character account was a relationship I
wanted a tourniquet around we proved up
defensive XD Khalifa did not have any
partner as I found 20 in a domino when
the modem escape said I have another
lazy differences on holidays I his
energy see only the lake city couldn't
in Eastern Ontario past oh no poor
foolish I existence comes as it couldn't
be a little tougher believe about all
the time so they stick a salute on a
traditional that's it if if these are
some interesting okay so seven explained
that she did not actually pose the
question that way and she define it she
made the distinction in lane CT you have
on the one hand a set of legal rules and
on the other hand is also a set of
subjective norms that are concerning
value is connected in the restaurant
thanks and her main point is to say that
lady did the risk if the blaze killed
sort of obfuscate the real questions
that are the questions to me repose
which are the practicing actual
practices all of the civil service
everybody who serves French state so on
the one hand they have to respect the
rules set by late day official policy of
entity but at the same time they it
happens that they have ignored and she
gave the example for example in the 80s
they were not intervening in the name of
density they say we cannot intervene in
everything having to do this because
because of rain in CT and in the 90s it
is in the name of the same lace detail
that they intervene to establish the
rain cetera concepts so not too much
emphasis on my table because it would
artist 8-time of practice she is
interesting because whenever I present
refrigerators people ask how would you
define too
the simpler state despite the existence
of guiana 70,000 most moms salaries well
when I asked her the question saying
that actually it's tightly related to
the central notion of assertive same
person but since the stay is an agent of
social engineering project like to make
religion something private in certain
cases like to repeat but those his
participation is very high the state has
the obligation to intervene aquatica so
to say listen therefore it tries to
control islam with control across trends
Imams it's part of a circuit of
secularism and we look at the french
example in 1905 there were three
proposals on the table before the
passing of des moines ireland one was
very marginal extreme by the free
thinkers liberal conservative homeless
homes it was anti religious it was
dropped then the two models one was the
control mode that turkey later adapted
that the comp even called the Prime
Minister 1904 defending the cultural
model saying that if we leave Catholic
Church separated its own it
dangers you should keep it down under
control but then the second model was a
separation mother I'll cibrian
adventures away and they they want the
game and then French embrace the
separations type of surgery same person
whether later turkey embrace the control
model of a shorter sentence when it
comes to Islam there isn't there they're
all switched not French is imitating the
church modified headscarf ban by the
French consul of Muslims Dumbrell
organization to control the most and
Imams so in this regard I find it very
linked to like that assertive sentence
but I still want to give some credit to
French practice this quite de Ojo a
circle second look because of several
reasons the passive sectors challenge or
because of the Democratic nature of the
French politics and the Kraken pack so
ideology is in the mind of policymakers
but the practice is always much more
accommodating and for example the cost
of state inference the Supreme Court of
a conservative affairs publish a report
which they are saying that Muslims are
never a disadvantaged position I own
Sarkozy sometimes articulate the same
point because historically they were now
about 40,000 catholic church buildings
in front despite the fact that they were
empty people are not attending mystics
have our time to find any place to
forgive aggravation the streets are full
of people try this therefore they say
we're going to be make some exemptions
exceptions in the nineteen oh five floor
and give some money and at the mayor
level now it is practice that some ways
providing money for most construction
despite the separation idea of later
revived so in practice there's a mixture
of a certain person but definitely idea
is the classical videos thank ya by the
way you have also made the point mind if
I was going to make
thank you again undergraduate at this
university um I'd like to focus on the
idea of incommensurability professor
molly cavalli talk um not when she
writes a daughter commencer ability she
relates it to two things one what Keynes
idea semiotic ideology so different
locations with materiality and ideas and
even a different idea village different
from the Buddha conceived by their
service secularism but aqua just talked
about my question is kind of extending
this discourse of incommensurate looking
at it and relating to notions out about
assertive seculars it's kind of just an
open question muslim liberal
intellectuals are trying to get into
commencer ability right and in fact what
I think
that the state is trying to do mr. this
comments your ability to our strategic
aims right so the ID that the recent
comments to depend on the table but if
there is that it has to be ejected from
public space right since whatever is in
conservative values of public you know
has to be that demands who are not
reliable demands that because there is
no even asking the question but you know
what about incremental be to convince I
thinking about so I think my phone was
not to think about the question of
detectors were almost burst after nine
eleven to bring things together to make
variant to fight for commencer ability
prices and so this tension to the muscle
community but also internal symbolic
violence so incommensurability wasn't
hard to be discussed anymore because it
was interesting violence while the 911
attacks we're in the way not even
understandable was commensurate with
what supposed to be the value
today I know this is a difficult
question the next session will be
starting at eleven fifteen so you
probably need the next seven minutes